all right um and she'll be talking about
the top weight chromology of a.g
thank you so much for the introduction
and thank you to all the organizers for
putting on this lovely conference it's
so nice to see you all
and i can't wait till next year to
hopefully see many of you in person
in the bay area at this as said i'm
juliette bruce i'm a new postdoc
at the university of california berkeley
i am also at msri for the year
before transplanting to the bay i was at
the university of wisconsin-madison
and today i'm going to talk about the
top weight chomology of a.g which will
tie
kind of in touch on many uh things that
were just kind of talked about
in the previous talk which will be nice
and this is all joint work with
madeleine brandt melody jan margarita
mello gwen moorland and corey wolfe
but before i get to the math i think
it's important to acknowledge a few
things
so first where i work and live occupies
the ancestral and current homeland at
the mukema alone tribe
and other familial descendants of the
sovereign verona band of alameda county
black and indigenous lives matter
further
where i work and live is only a few
miles away from the site of compton's
cafeteria
where 51 years ago in the face of
transphobia police violence and
state violence one of the first actions
in the modern lgbt movement
occurred led by black brown and
indigenous trans women of color
happy trans week of visibility to all
those who celebrate black and indigenous
lgbtq lives matter
with that all said let me shift to kind
of the math that i want to
talk about today and so the central
object for the first part of this talk
is going to be two sets so the first set
is going to be omega g
which is going to be the set of positive
definite g by g
real matrices so i want to think about
this as being some
subset of the space of all g by g
symmetric matrices
right and so remember a matrix is
positive definite if the quadratic form
it defines
is strictly greater than zero on all
non-zero vectors so you do x
x a x transpose and that gives you some
real number
and if that real number is greater than
zero for all nonzero vectors
then we're positive definite and so this
space omega g
forms a nice convex cone inside the
space of all
g by g symmetric matrices um
but while that it's a nice cone it's
convex
it is definitely not closed for example
the cone point even which would
correspond to the zero matrix is not
positive definite so we don't even have
a cone point in our cone
and so what we want to do is instead
consider a partial
closure of this space so what we call
omega grt which is known as the
rational closure of omega g
which is the set of positive
semi-definite g by g matrices whose
kernel is
rational so if i wanted to take this
cone
and close it up completely i would get
the set of all
positive definite g by g matrices but
that's too many things to work with for
our interest
um so instead we take this partial one
where we kind of on
the boundary we throw in a dense set of
points
and what those points are are exactly
the positive definite matrix which if i
write down
their kernel and i write a basis for
their kernel
that basis consists of vectors
uh whose coordinates are rational so
this cone is still topologically not at
a closed
set of the g by g real symmetric
matrices but it's much
closer to being closed for example doing
this throws in the zero matrix and so we
now get a cone point
here um which is great
and so this set the rational closure of
omega g will kind of be the star player
for our show
and there's an important thing to note
which is that there's a natural action
of glgz
the group of g by g invertible matrices
naturally acts on
omega g rt and that action is given by
given
an element q we can just send it to
aq a transpose
where a is an element of glgz
so i'm just saying if i do a q a
transpose
and the resulting matrix will be
positive
or positive semi-definite still and the
kernel will still be rational
as long as i started out with a matrix
who is which was also positive
semi-definite
and whose kernel was also rational
so this naturally acts on this big cone
it's going to swirl it around
so what's considered an example that
has strategically been hidden the entire
time so if g equals two
so we're looking at two by two symmetric
matrices well
that forms an r three worth of
worth of matrices and the best way to
describe a cone in
r3 at least via the distance of zoom is
to draw a hyperplane section of the cone
so i take my cone in r3
i cut it with a hyperplane and what i
get is
some circle looking thing with a
boundary
that's not quite all the way filled in
so it's kind of a dense set of points in
the boundary
and it looks like a circle what type of
points are out
on the boundary so let me give you a few
of them there's one
zero zero zero zero zero zero one
and then one's on the diagonal minus
one's on the off diagonal you can check
that
all of these matrices are going to be
positive definite
or positive semi-definite with rational
kernel but won't be positive definite
we also get the cone point off in the
distance and you could then also look at
the action of gl2z on these points and
see where they start to move around when
you let gl
to z act i i will tell you already
that there is an element of g there are
elements of gl2z
that will take any one of these two
points that will switch any of the two
points you want while fixing the third
so somehow
under the action of gl2z these points
are all identified in some ways
and so this cone is lovely but it has
one
uh bad property which is that it is
not polyhedral and non-polyhedral cones
scare me somewhat
um just being an algebraic geometer
anything that's not
polyhedra no non-polyhedral cones are
things i don't necessarily love in my
life
and so what we want to do is find a way
to approximate it by
rational polyhedral cones and so the way
to do this is with something called the
perfect
cone decomposition which i want to think
about as being a recipe
to produce an infinite collection of
rational polyhedral cones
which will approximate the space omega
grt
and so the recipe starts like this so
you input to your recipe
one g by g positive definite matrix
and then you take your g by usually
positive
definite matrix and you look at the set
of all integer
vectors that are non-zero which minimize
that quadratic form q so i say you take
x and you take q and you say is x
q x transpose as small as possible over
all possible
integer vectors so we ask right this is
essentially
we want that x transpose q x
is less than or equal to y transpose q
y for all y
and z to the g without zero
so i'm just thinking about all of the in
essentially
right this quadratic this positive
definite matrix is defining a notion of
distance on the lattice and i'm looking
at the vectors of short integer vectors
of shortest
length with respect to q and so this
it turns out will be some finite set of
integer vectors
and now i have to take those vectors and
tell you how do i get symmetric g by g
matrices out of them
well if you gave me a vector and i want
a symmetric matrix the easiest thing to
do
is just to do vector vector transpose to
get a g by g symmetric matrix
and that's exactly what we do so we then
construct a cone which we denote sigma
of q
by looking at the cone spanned by the
rays
x x transpose where x is one of these
vectors of shortest length so
there's kind of two steps to the recipe
first you take your quadratic form
your positive definite matrix you find
the vectors of shortest length
you convert those vectors of shortest
length to rank one symmetric matrices
and you look at the cone spanned by
these rank 1 symmetric matrices
and finally we let sigma of g or sigma
pg
be the set of all such cones so for you
look at all possible
positive definite matrices so we have
one cone for each positive definite
matrix
so it's a lot of cones and this is the
perfect cone decomposition so this set
of cones is called the perfect cone
decomposition of omega g
we might call the cones that are in it
perfect cones
is it important saying gl z
instead of glq or slq
yes um we want some integral structure
to be maintained essentially exactly
um i think you might i think there are
other chances you could replace these
things with
actions of other interesting groups
other interesting modular groups if you
wanted to look at other
um modular spaces but i don't think
that's
here or there for right now so let's
look at what this looks like in an
example so again
g equals two right the recipe tells you
i have to get you have to give me
a two by two positive definite symmetric
matrix and so i claim that
one's on the diagonal one half's off
diagonal is a positive definite matrix
if you do x x transpose you'll see that
it corresponds to the quadratic form
x squared x y y squared and of course
you might check readily now that this
polynomial is
strictly greater than zero for all
non-zero vectors
and so this is the input to my recipe
and the first step in the recipe is to
knead out
the minimal vector the vectors of
minimal length so
the smallest this polynomial can be on
an integer vector is
one and we achieve that minimum value of
one at the vectors plus or minus one 0
plus or minus 0 1 and plus or minus
1 minus 1. so these are the only vectors
integer vectors you plug in
and you'll get the minimum value of 1.
so there's six vectors and then for each
of these six
vectors i do vector vector transpose to
construct
a two by two symmetric matrix of rank
one so for example here
if i do one zero i'm going to get the
matrix one zero zero
zero likewise if i do the vector 1 minus
1 i'm going to get
1 minus 1 minus 1 1 and likewise we'll
get this matrix from here
note the pluses or minuses don't matter
the minus signs will cancel out when you
do vector vector transpose so instead of
getting
six rays here i get three these three
symmetric matrices
that are positive semi-definite and you
can check that they have rational
kernels so i take
the cone spanned by these three rays so
in my picture
again remember this is a
three-dimensional cone and so we're
going to look at it by taking a
hyperplane section
right i take these three rays which i've
already told you were on the boundary
and then i'm looking at the cone spanned
by them which is exactly
this triangle here that's shaded in red
and also in gray
so this is one cone in the perfect cone
decomposition of
omega 2 rt you would then have to do
this for every other possible
2 by 2 positive definite matrix um
although it will turn out
that if you just start letting gl2z act
on this
cone in gray you'll see that it starts
flipping around
in interesting ways and will actually
eventually
fill up the entire space so in fact up
to the action of gl2z
there is exactly one cone of dimension
three
namely the gray cone there is one cone
of dimension two
namely whichever face of the grey cone
you want to pick
there is one cone of dimension one
whichever ray
pick that one and of course there's only
one cone of dimension zero namely the
cone point
okay so this is some recipe
and we see that a priori produces
some infinite collection of cones and
the nice thing is
that it's a theorem of voronoi dating
back to in some ways to 1908
that this recipe produces a very nice
collection of cones so the perfect cone
decomposition
sigma g upper p constructed
as we discussed above has the following
nice properties so first
all the cones are going to be rational
polyhedral cones
those are the cone and a finite number
of rays
and those rays all have rationing of it
given by rational vectors
secondly this set covers the rational
closure of omega g so if you union
all of these perfect cones you get
exactly omega grt
secondly uh it is
has nice properties with respect to
these cones so cones
uh the set is closed undertaking faces
so if you take a face of a cone in here
it's also in one of a perfect cone
and if you take the intersection of two
cones those cones will intersect along a
face
and thus also be per a perfect cone
so this set is closed under
intersections and taking faces
and finally we have two properties that
say this set of cones while
infinite plays really well with respect
to the action of glgz
so first it's closed under the action of
glgz so as you let glgz act
these cones might flip around so this
cone might move over here and then over
here
but up to the when you let glgz act the
set
of such perfect cones is closed and
finally while there's an
infinite number of uh perfect cones
up to the action of glgz there's only a
finite number of orbits
and this is really useful because
essentially what this is saying is that
this perfect cone decomposition is a
finite amount of data
right in some sense you specify a finite
number of cones
and then you start letting glgz act and
it starts just kind of tessellating
the picture in some nice way so really
you're
able to approximate this non
this convex non-polyhedral cone uh by a
finite number of cone
of rational polyhedral cones up to some
complicated but still nice action of
glgz
i'll note that this that sets of
cones that satisfy this property have a
special name in the literature
these are known as admissible
decompositions at least in
algebraic geometry and they're very
important to kind of the study of
compact moduli spaces
um in some ways and then you're welcome
to ask me more about that later but i
won't say much more
so the last definition i want to give
about these cones is to note that we're
going to say a cone is alternating
if given an element of glgz that fixes
the cone so if a
sigma a transpose is sigma itself
so it fixes it as a set then a
has to be orientation preserving on
sigma so what do i mean
well if a sigma a transpose is sigma
that means a essentially induces a map
of topological spaces
from sigma to itself and this map of
topological spaces or manifold with
boundary or corners or whatever you want
to say
has to be orientation preserving right
so it can't somehow take that cone
and mirror it or flip it in some weird
non-orientation preserving way
so again
looking at our favorite example for the
day when g equals two this was the
picture
i said there are exactly three cones of
top of each
one cone of each dimension up to the
action of gl2z
if we look for example at the gray cone
we have to ask
is there an orientation reversing action
of gl2z
on this cone and i claim there is
in fact i'll leave it as an exercise
it's not too hard and a little bit fun
to show that you can find an element of
gl2z
that's going to mirror this entire
picture over the red dashed line so it's
going to take
this point up here down here and going
to fix
this ray in particular it's going to
mirror sigma 2
it's also going to mirror this facet
sigma 1
and this mirroring action will exactly
tell us that both
sigma 2 and sigma 1
are not alternating
on the other hand the other cones we
have are this ray
sigma zero and the cone point and while
the ray is kind of fixed at the base by
the cone point
and what would it mean to mirror a
one-dimensional thing it means you'd
have to flip it like this
but your cone point is fixed so both
sigma zero
and sigma uh minus one are
are alternating so sigma zero and sigma
minus one
are altering
so there are exactly two gl2z
equivalence classes of cones that are
alternating
in this picture namely the ray and the
cone point
uh juliet yes there's a question in the
chat um about the picture you drew is
that
um part of just one orbit uh what would
a different orbit look like
um so thanks for raising the question so
this
picture i've drawn here so up to the
action everything is
um for g equals two there's only one
orbit in each dimension
so everything is kind of identified
there's only one thing
um this is roughly this the case
for small g so i think for g equals
three this is also true in higher
dimensions though you can get multiple
distinct gl
gz orbits and um i don't have a good way
to picture it but somehow
it's just different cones that can touch
and somehow
their faces might get equip the
equivalent under the glgz action but the
whole cones can get moved around
it turns out to be quite complicated uh
how these things can behave
but thank you so much for the question
um
so what do i want to do with this so
right by that theorem of voronoi
there are a finite number of gmg
orbits of each cone and so what i want
to do
is consider that was the wrong thing to
do
i want to consider the perfect chain
complex which i'm going to call the
perfect complex
denoted pg and i'm going to let that be
the chain complex
where in degree k it's going to be the
finite the
uh the q finite dimensional q vector
space
indexed by the orbits of alternating
cones
in dimension k plus one so i look at all
cones of dimension k plus one
i look up to the action of g l g z
there's a finite number of those orbits
at each orbit i take those each orbit
and i say are you
alternating if so i keep you
and i just look at the q vector space
spanned by such
cones and then i put a differential on
this
in kind of the natural way namely i take
an alternating sum
over all co-dimension one faces of my
cone
and what should this what should how
should i determine this minus 1 sign
well there's three answers
one it's exactly the convention that you
need to make this a chain complex
slightly more accurately maybe it's the
convention you normally use when you're
writing a cellular chain complex and
apology
even more accurately you might say you
fix a reference orientation on all
representatives of your cones and you
ask whether the in
the reference orientation on the facet
agrees with the induced orientation
from the larger cone so there's many
different ways to think about the minus
sign but
really you just want to have something
that forms a chain complex so this is a
complex of finite dimensional q vector
spaces
indexed by these perfect cones
and again we can consider an example
here
when g equals two right i said
there are no alternating perfect cones
of dimension three
there are no alternating perfect cones
of dimension two
there is one alternating perfect cone of
dimension
zero of dimension one namely the ray up
here
and there's one alternating perfect cone
of dimension
zero namely the cone point and so this
chain complex with g
equals two is just zero zero q
q and the map is just going to be
multiplication by plus or minus one
depending on which you like
either way this one map in the chain
complex is going to be an isomorphism
and the homology of this chain complex
is going to be zero
for all k um so
the main theorem i want to state today
is the following
um and it's a theorem again of myself
madeleine brandt melody chen margarita
mello corey wolf
and corey wolf which says that for g
between two and seven
the homology of this complex pg that
remember we constructed from these
perfect
cones is zero except in the following
cases so
when g equals three uh it's non-zero in
degree five
for g equals five it's non-zeroed in
degrees nine and 14
for g equals 6 it's non-zero and degree
11
and g equals 7 is non-zero and degree 13
18
22 and 27 and
if you look at these numbers for a hot
second you might think
well 5 9 11 13 that roughly looks like
2g minus 1.
and so you might quest ask the question
or conjecture
that for g greater than or equal to 5 is
the homology in degree two g minus one
of this complex non-zero
so that's what we saw here um and i this
question is open
for g bigger than seven but i think
would be really interesting to know
the answer to this um in part it is
related
in some ways to some very interesting
connections to things like the modulized
space of curves and work of
gladys pain and tan it also kind of
touches on some interesting connections
between these cones
this perfect cone complex and can save
which is graph complex
in some ways i won't talk about here but
so
this is the main result i want to
mention but on my title i wasn't talking
about this perfect cone complex i said
this
was a talk about the top weight comology
of a.g and the reason for that is the
following result
due again to myself madeleine brant
melanie chan margarita mello cory wolf
and gwen moorland although we recently
found out this you can also deduce such
a theorem from
okada oshida which says that there
exists a canonical isomorphism
between the homology of this perfect
of the homology of this perfect cone
chain complex that we described above
that's entirely combinatorial right it
comes from cones of g by g symmetric
matrices
up to some action of g by g invertible
matrices and
um this complicated gadget on the right
which is the top weight chomology of ag
so let me break this down
so ag here is the moduli
space of a billion varieties
of dimension g and we should think about
and abelian
the iberian varieties came up in the
previous talk but if you've never really
seen them
uh you can just think about them as
being algebraic varieties
that have a natural group structure um
so the
quintessential example of these things
are elliptic curves so elliptic curves
are curves given by the vanishing of a
polynomial
but also the points of these of the
curves magically have a group structure
and so ebelian varieties are
generalizations of this you can think
about them as being
over the complex numbers at least just
being tori so you can think of them as
being some big donuts
um and the modular space of abelian
varieties is just some
space a topological space a variety
a stack whatever you want to call it
whose points exactly parametrize these
things so you have some topological
space
you give me a point in that space and i
can think about that as giving me an
abelian variety
i'll note that the dimension of this
variety
is g plus 1 choose 2 which is also going
to be d
in this equation so when you see 2d
minus k
the d is just the dimension of this
space
and then the other thing here right is
what is this this is the top weight
commonology
and so what do i mean by that well i
have some topological space so it makes
sense to talk about the rational
commonology of it
but we're not going to just talk about
all of the rational cohomology but
instead
what's called the top weight comology
which is essentially
just a canonical quotient
of
this of my comology group
right so i'm looking at some there's
some way to construct a specific
quotient
of the normal rational chromology and
that's what i'm looking at so i'm
looking at a very small piece of the
comology
of ag
if you want to be more precise what you
would say is that the
commonology of ag carries a weight
filtration coming from deling's theory
of weights and mixed todd structures
and that weight filtration is supported
in degrees zero up to 2d
and we're looking at the associated
graded in degree 2d
um and so what's important about this
theorem is it exactly translates our
previous result about the homology of
the perfect cone
chain complex into a result about the
comology of a g namely the coimology of
a g
for g between two and seven
is zero except in the following cases
and something i'll end by noting is that
you'll notice here that
we get chomology in degrees 15 33 and 37
and those are odd numbers
and this in fact answers a question
asked by sam graceffsky namely
is there does the modulized space ag
have
any odd chromology and the reason you
might ask this question that seems like
an odd one if you've never thought about
it but
often when we're working with things
over the complex numbers any homology
class we can construct geometrically
it lives in even dimension just because
the fact that it has
even real dimension and so an amazing
thing
is this kind of combinatorial framework
of looking at these perfect cones
and this comparison isomorphism gives
us a way to get our hands on interesting
chorology classes and algebraic geometry
from a very combinatorial perspective
that previously we didn't necessarily
know
um and so i think i'll end by just
saying i think this is the start of a
much
more rich story it would be great to be
able to construct for example an
infinite class of homology classes for
ag or for example be able to compute
all of the top weight coalmonalogy or
the top weight euler characteristic
there are a lot of outstanding questions
and i think this result
i've talked about here today is just
kind of laying a lot of the groundwork
to try to use these interesting
combinatorial tools
to study a really interesting space in
algebraic geometry and
again thank you so much to the
organizers and the audience for
listening
let's uh thank the speaker
can i get some real clapping going
cool are there any questions from the
audience